er dir die erste Frage an Sie wir würden
sie bevor wir gleich übers Auto sprechen
den aktuellen Zustand der FDP innerhalb
der Ampel beschreiben konzentriertes
Arbeiten sie haben es gerade eingangs
erwähnt die FDP ist angetreten 2021 bei
der Bundestagswahl um das Land zu
modernisieren das machen wir Stück für
Stück und es gibt immer wieder
Entscheidungen die mir einen Tick zu
langsam gehen Thema
planungsbeschleunigung die Frage was
wollen wir Schiene oder Straße wir sagen
wir wollen beides beschleunigen in
Deutschland manche Entscheidungen
könnten schneller laufen aber
konzentriertes Arbeiten und gerade wenn
wir bei Autoverkehr reden haben wir in
dieser Woche eine ganz wichtige
Entscheidung getroffen beim Thema
Verbrenner reden
sie müssen da ja bald nicht mehr
arbeiten weil sie fliegen ja gerade
überall raus das Ziel ist erfolgreich zu
sein politisch keine Frage aber es geht
es geht es geht zuerst mal darum die
Modernisierungsprojekte auf die wir uns
vereinbart haben umzusetzen und ich gebe
zu vor manchen Landtagswahlen hat mich
schon geärgert dass Entscheidung
verzögert worden sind denken sie da saß
ich glaube ich hier mit Lars Klingbeil
wenn ich mich richtig erinnere an die
Debatte um das Thema
Laufzeitverlängerung Kernkraftwerke das
kam dann nach der niedersächsischen
Landtagswahl jetzt nach der Berliner
Wahl haben wir Entscheidungen getroffen
über die wir gleich reden werden um
beispielsweise synthetische Kraftstoffe
zuzulassenisierungsprojekte von denen
ich mir manchmal wünschen würde dass wir
da schneller sind gut ist dass wir
solche Entscheidungen aber treffen
denken Sie an das in schlechten ist dass
ihnen
mal kurz ausführen an der Stelle denken
wir an das Entlastungsvolumen 50
Milliarden Euro für Arbeitnehmer
ja und im letzten Jahr ein lng-terminal
in Wilhelmshaven aus unserer Gemeinde
niedersächsischen Heimat in Betrieb
genommen also diese Regierung schafft
Modernisierungsprojekte in der
Kommunikation würde ich mir die
Geschwindigkeit die wir uns selbst
vorgenommen haben manchmal noch mehr
verwirklicht sehen wer ist denn
verantwortlich für diese
miesenergebnisse außer Christen also
verantwortlich ist man zunächst mal
selbst sogar keine Frage die FDP ist die
Partei der Eigenverantwortung da schiebt
man nicht Verantwortung Weg noch mal
auch alle gemeinsam wir sagen immer eins
zu Recht jeder Wahlkampf ist einer der
gesamten FDP und so führen wir Sie auch
und
Liberalismus die Idee der Freiheit der
Eigenverantwortung gerade in
Krisenzeiten ist nicht immer einfach und
ist alles andere als bequem Christian
Lindner sagt zurecht immer während der
FDP ist braucht starke Nerven die haben
war ich glaube in der Mittelfrist zahlt
sich auf wenn man dazu steht was man
gesagt hat auch im Wahlkampf da gibt es
auch Gegenwind zwischendurch aber dazu
stehen was man gesagt hat und das auch
in Politik umzusetzen ist die richtige
Strategie Frau Künstler warum gibt es
denn da diesen Abschluss diese ganzen
Misere was glauben wie unterschiedlich
man auf diese Realität kommen kann
wenn man das tun würde
mir gerade vor sie tun das war sie im
Wahlkampf gesagt haben dann müssten ihre
Wähler ja eigentlich zufrieden sein und
ihre Zustimmungsraten nach oben gehen
und sie gehen ja eher deutlich nach
unten mein Eindruck dieser Koalition ist
eher und besonders der FDP ist dass sie
vieles verhindert also nehmen wir es
Energieeffizienzgesetz oder den
schnellen Ausbau von Wind und Solar das
sind alles Projekte die lange nicht
funktioniert haben oder nicht
funktionieren weil die FDP im Bundestag
immer gebremst hat also die Partei die
für Innovation steht die bei der sehe
ich im Moment nicht so viel Innovation
nehmen sie nur noch ein Beispiel Thema
Digitalisierung mir fällt jetzt nicht so
richtig ein Projekt ein wo die FDP in
letzter Zeit bei der Digitalisierung so
richtig so ein Wumms erzeugt hat gerade
Internationalisierung im Verkehrsbereich
Volker Wissing hat den in den
Vereinigten Staaten bekommen ich will
aber das Beispiel
für die Frage von autonomen parken
beispielsweise autonome
effizienter beispielsweise in Städten
ist hinbekommen kann das Parkplätze
gesehen haben
es geht es geht darum Standard zu setzen
und Deutschland hat ist tatsächlich das
erste Land der Welt was hier Standard
setzt an diesem Preis was ist das für
ein Preis ist für ein Preis den Volker
wissinger erhalten von wem von Experten
internationalen expertenzahl im Rahmen
einer Messe in Las Vegas von
internationalen Experten die gesagt
haben wer hat zurzeit gute
digitalisierungsideen im Straßenverkehr
und wir haben verdient ja das waren wir
tatsächlich in Deutschland deswegen sage
ich Ja und bin dankbar sein dass ich
sagen darf danke haben
ich wollte eigentlich das Beispiel was
dürfen
die Idee bei diesem autonomen parken die
Idee ist dass wir effizienter
digitalisiert am Straßenverkehr
unterwegs
wir werden das auch beim autonomen kann
man weitermachen beispielsweise sie
können in Parkhäuser dann in Zukunft
reinfahren und das Auto kann sich dann
mit neuer Technologie von alleine parken
und dafür brauchen sie klare Standards
und Deutschland ist Vorreiter aber das
kann man noch nicht das kann man zurzeit
einfach kann aber Digitalisierung ist
immer auch Zukunftsgestaltung und
natürlich kann man sagen braucht man
sich nicht darum kümmern sollen sollen
wir andere Länder dann hinterher kein
Deutschland war immer gut daran denken
Sie beispielsweise an MP3 Player wir
haben das alles erfunden und nie zum
Einsatz gebracht in Deutschland wir sind
jetzt ein Land was hier standardsets und
bei Digitalisierung im Straßenverkehr
Vorreiter ist international auch
Digitalisierung in Parkhäusern sind wir
offensichtlich Vorreiter
oder da sind wir konkret das sind wir
suchen konkretes Beispiel nennen im
Straßenverkehr werden wir es immer mehr
aber dass ich mir mehr Digitalisierung
im Straßenverkehr Wünsche beispielsweise
bei der Frage der Verkehrsbeeinflussung
dass man Verkehre intelligenter leiten
kann das weniger Staus entstehen da
müssen wir mehr machen da ist noch nicht
alles in 13 Monaten passiert war leider
viel liegen geblieben ist aber das sind
Dinge die wir anfassen zur Zeit das sind
Modernisierungsprojekte aber jetzt würde
ich schon noch ganz gerne auf den sagen
wir mal Vorwurf von Frau Künstler
eingehen dass die FDP bremsen würde
beispielsweise beim Stromnetz ausbaut
wir werden in dieser Woche am Freitag im
Deutschen Bundestag eingesetzt
durchbringen wo es genau darum geht wo
es darum geht die Stromnetze schneller
auszubauen der Vorschlag kann von der
FDP zu sagen wir wollen schneller sein
bei Energiespeichern wir wollen
schneller sein die Stromnetze in Gang zu
bekommen damit wir die Energiewende
vernünftig schaffen das sind alles
fortschrittsprojekte die auch dazu
gehören dazu gehört aber eben genauso
auch bei der Infrastruktur mehr zu
investieren und schneller zu sein also
das Training die FDP würde an der Stelle
Bremsen ist widerlich durch doch doch
aktives Regierungshandeln weitere
Beispiele die ich widerlegt habe einen
schönen Satz für sie ja gerne wenn es
keinen Straßenbau mehr gibt dann gibt's
auch keine neuen Stromleitung mehr da
kann sich der Robert gehackt legen
des Deutschen Bundestages sogar und hat
sehr zugespitzt gesagt das war aufpassen
müssen dass wir uns Ernte nicht
gegenseitig blockieren denn das
Spannende ist wir haben uns im
Koalitionsvertrag auf beides geeinigt
den schnelleren Stromnetz Ausbau das
machen wir beispielsweise diese Woche im
Bundestag und die planungsbeschleunigung
über alles Wasser im Koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart haben deswegen bedauere ich
dass die Grünen dort gerade blockieren
ist die Halbierung der Planungs- und
genehmigungszeiten für die gesamte
Infrastruktur in Deutschland dazu steht
die SPD und dazu steht die FDP bei den
Grünen wünsche ich mir das jetzt auch
dazu ja sagen also sie haben sich im
Koalitionsvertrag darauf geeinigt
Straßen zu bauen Autobahnen zu bauen
selbstverständlich okay und die meisten
wichtig ja es ist festgelegt im
Kollektiv dass wir 1,5 Grad Ziel
erreichen wollen müssen sogar sehr
wichtig ja das klimaschinen wirklich
wichtig das ist eines unserer zentralen
Anliegen ich habe mal meine Diplomarbeit
an der Universität Hannover über das
Thema Klimaschutzpolitik und dann wollen
sie neue Straßen und neue Autobahn bauen
ja auch weil sie das Klimaschutz wurde
beschränken sie mich nicht auf das eine
Herr lands ich sage ja nicht ich will
Straßen und die Grünen wollen Schiene
ich sage ich will beides oder wie finden
Sie das wenn Sie das hören
[Musik]
wo wir nicht den Verkehr oder das Auto
in den Mittelpunkt stellen sondern das
was der Bedarf an Mobilität für Menschen
ist für Pendler und Pendler
beispielsweise die brauchen nicht das
Auto das ist nicht Gott gegeben das
Straßennetz in Deutschland ist sehr sehr
breit auch in die Jahre gekommen also
Sanierung im Bestand das lese ich heraus
aus diesem
Koalitionsvertrag das wird auch von
grüner Seite mitgetragen aber noch so
eine Art klimaautobahn zu bauen also
diese Rechnung die geht nicht darauf es
funktioniert nicht die Gegenfrage
stellen warum haben sich denn SPD und
Grüne in Niedersachsen auf dem Bau der
Küsten Autobahn geeinigt und
Koalitionsvertrag also das das wäre dann
ja auch aber müssen sie kurz bitte warum
das wissen selber lieber die Prozesse
gerade Planfeststellungsverfahren Süd
schnell weg auch da sind Fakten
geschaffen worden das ist ja also da
sind wir zusammen diese Planungszyklen
wir haben planungszyten von 10 15 Jahren
der der viel zu lang sind Generation von
Politikern teilweise nicht mehr dabei
wenn so ein Projekt gestartet ist und
sozusagen dann der der Bau und das ist
zu lang das muss kürzer sein da muss die
BürgerInnenbeteiligung schneller stärker
dabei sein aber das Planen
Feststellungsverfahren ist da
abgeschlossen das ist ja Teil auch das
Koalitionsvertrags leider auch auf
Bundesebene dass diese Projekte nicht
mehr angefasst werden noch mal
also sie sagen wir sind Fortschritt ja
wir sind der Motor des Fortschritts sie
wollen Autobahn bauen um das Klima zu
schützen sie wollen im Zweifel mehr
Autoverkehr als weniger Autoverkehr um
das Klima zu schützen sie verhindern
gerade auf EU-Ebene dass der Verbrenner
ab 2035 Geschichte ist ja und sie wollen
kein Tempolimit und sie sitzen hier und
sagen das Thema ist mir wirklich
wahnsinnig wichtig ja weil sie dann das
ist Fortschritt und ich sage Ihnen dann
fünf verlorene Landtagswahlen ich sage
Ihnen warum reden wir darüber
die Koalition
entgegen dessen was unterstellt wird ja
einige Dinge voranbringt diesen Dienstag
entschieden ich glaube das was wir
Dienstag gemacht haben ich führe das
gleich aus ist die Zeiten wenn in der
Verkehrspolitik die Ampelkoalition
Berlin hat entschieden dass wir bereit
sind in Deutschland vollenden umfänglich
synthetische Kraftstoffe zuzulassen die
klimaneutral hergestellt werden können
das wäre ein echter Fortschritt vom über
45 Millionen Verbrenner Autos haben wir
in Deutschland kann man natürlich die
Politik fahren und sagen die wollen wir
schlecht machen die wollen wir nicht
haben okay ist schlecht das ist
60%, das ist interessant sie machen
daraus so einen Glaubenskrieg nein ich
habe gesagt ich will beides ich will den
ÖPNV besser ausgebaut werden
die Leute kommen sonst durcheinander es
gibt diese Vereinbarung 2035 EU-weit
Verbrenner aus es gibt noch keine
Vereinbarung das Gegenteil ist ja
richtig das ist der Plan auf ihn das ist
der Plan ist Europäischen Parlaments und
Mitgliedstaaten das sehen hier
Deutschland sprechen in Brüssel brennt
gerade richtig die Hütte weil ihr
Verkehrsminister Herr wissen also Stopp
von der FDP sagt wir als Deutschland
werden wir haben den zwar schon mal
zugestimmt und haben das auch
vorverhandelt ist also ich plötzlich
deswegen kenne ich die Abläufe nun
wirklich ganz gut es gibt den
sogenannten Trilog da muss ich der Rat
und die die Regierung das Parlament und
die EU-Kommission zusammensetzen und
sagen wie kommen wir denn jetzt zusammen
und das war vor einer ganzen Weile und
da haben sich alle wie lange ungefähr
ich will das mal verstehen wie lange ist
das her das ist ungefähr das war vor
Weihnachten okay
Monaten gelaufen genau die haben sich
darauf geeinigt das machen wir jetzt das
war sehr schwer und da haben sich auch
die in der Bundesregierung schon die
Umweltministerin mit dem
Verkehrsminister ordentlich gefetzt und
sie haben sich dann aber geeinigt und
diese Einigung auf eu-ebenebene sind ja
nicht ganz einfach herzustellen das sind
27 Regierungen mit diversen Parteien
dahinter und die haben alle gesagt wir
machen das jetzt und dann muss das noch
im Gesetzestext gegossen werden und das
ist passiert und dann wird das von
Parlament verabschiedet die Kommission
hat das Okay gegeben bei den Ministerrat
ist das eigentlich nur eine Formalität
dass man dann auch ja sagt und jetzt
macht ausgerechnet Deutschland wo alle
wissen all dieses Deutschland da haben
wir sowieso häufig Probleme wegen der
gasgeschichte extrem und weil die reden
immer diese Klimaschutz wollen dann am
Ende machen sie es doch nicht da sagt
dann ist die FDP das haben wir nicht so
gemeint da gehen wir dann jetzt doch
nicht mit
wirklich ihre ja so ist es ja eindeutig
nicht das Ergebnis des Trilux kennt Frau
penzler auch vollumfänglich ist nämlich
ein sehr klare Festlegung der einzige
Grund warum man sich auf dieses
sogenannte Trilog das heißt ein
Kompromiss zwischen Kommission
Europäischen Parlament und die
Mitgliedstaaten weil die Mitgliedstaaten
da rein verhandeln konnten nicht nur
Deutschland weil man ja nicht die
einzigen das ist kein Verbrenner aus
nach 2035 gibt für solche
Verbrennungsmotoren die klimaneutral
betrieben werden können das ist ein
eindeutig beschlossen jetzt hat ein
Kommissionsmitglied gesagt das
interessiert mich nicht und dann sagt
Deutschland zu Recht und andere
Mitgliedstaaten auch viele Osteuropäer
andere springen ja gerade bei und sagen
das kann ja wohl nicht angehen wir haben
uns darauf verständigt dass wir nach 20
35 auch Verbrennungsmotoren zulassen
wollen wenn sie klimaneutral beschrieben
werden können deswegen ist die
Entscheidung in Deutschland der
deutschen Koalition so wichtig gewesen
an diesen Dienstag dass wir gesagt haben
wir wollen diese Verbrennungsmotoren in
Zukunft mit klimaneutralen Kraftstoffen
betreiben können jetzt kann man
natürlich sagen
Koalition ja aber die Koalition hat ja
gemeinsam beschlossen und es war ja ohne
großes Tamtam weil sonst kritisieren sie
ja vielleicht auch nicht ganz zu Unrecht
dass ich oft gestritten wird das haben
wir relativ locker finde ich jedenfalls
relativ geräuschlos hinbekommen zu sagen
wir wollen etwas erlauben ich bin nicht
der Überzeugung dass nach 2035 wird
durch ausschließlich Elektromobilität wo
wir in Deutschland gerade das Problem
haben dass das Braunkohlekraftwerke
hochfahren müssen ausschließlich durch
Elektromobilität die klimawände
hinbekommen das werden wir nicht
schaffen sie brauchen auch okay
klimaneutrale Kraftstoff und Verkehr
damit eben auch den Verbrennungsmotor
und diese Technologie Aufenthalt haben
Sie Recht das hat die FDP reinverhandelt
und der Grund warum wir jetzt in Brüssel
sagen das wollen wir dann auch
durchgesetzt werden ist eben dass das
trilog-verfahren zur Zeit im Abschluss
ist aber das was da reinfahren ist das
muss der Grund ist
also was hat das denn jetzt ganz konkret
mit der Frage
35 im gesamte Europa in dem größten
Wirtschaftsraum der Welt ob wir in
Zukunft dann noch Verbrennungsmotoren
stattfinden
während alle anderen Länder der Welt
sagen natürlich brauchen wir den
Verbrennungsmotor wir müssen den
klimaneutral sind denn alle anderen
Länder der Welt da denken Sie
beispielsweise an die Vereinigten
Staaten von Amerika denken Sie
beispielsweise eines Verbrenner aus
genauso beschlossen einziger als
einziger Bundesstaat als einziger
Bundesstaaten die acht größte
Volkswirtschaft dieses einziger
bundeswirtschaft ich will was was mir
was mehr an der Debatte ich glaube in
Wahrheit reden wir gerade über was
anderes wir reden über zwei höchst
unterschiedliche Denkschule die eine
Denkschule sagt wir müssen weniger
Wachstum haben wir müssen weniger
konsumieren und wir müssen weniger Auto
fahren und das führt dann zum Erfolg um
beispielsweise Klima zu erreichen ich
habe gehört der anderen Denkschule an
ich sage wir brauchen mehr
technologieoffenheit mehr Optionen und
das ist zurzeit etwas was übrigens auch
gar nicht ich habe von den Grünen so
sehr interessiert wird mehr
Wasserstoffantrieb die Frage von
synthetischen Kraftstoffen nicht immer
nur aus Technologien aussteigen und
übrigens ist es etwas mit dem
Deutschland schon mal erfolgreich war in
den 70er Jahren denken Sie mal an die
Zeit für freie Bürger denken Sie mal an
die Zeit als der Club of Rome gesagt hat
grenzendes Wachstum ist es alles vorbei
und damals hat Deutschland gesagt nein
wir wollen dass die Flüsse wieder klar
werden waren erfolgreich damit nicht
dass wir die chemische Industrie
verdrängt haben verboten haben sondern
durch Innovation geklappt und wenn sie
jetzt nach der FDP Politik Fragen ja das
ist DNA FDP
technologieoffenheit mehr zu lassen mehr
erlauben mehr Optionen gleichzeitig
Autobahn und gleichzeitig die
Klimaschutzziele zu erreichen was kann
dagegen sprechen Klimaschutzziele durch
mehr Technologien zu erreichen also
die technologieoffenheit ist ja nicht
das Thema aber wie wäre es doch
natürlich Ehrlichkeit wie viel wie viel
wie viel Prozent mehr Strom weil sie
gerade sagten immer so komische so
komische Erzählungen aufgebaut haben sie
auch gerade gemacht
wir brauchen wahnsinnig viel mehr Strom
wie viel Strom brauchen wir mehr wenn
wir alle Autos in Deutschland
elektrifizieren was schätzen Sie wir
werden in etwa zwei Drittel mehr
gebrauchen für den Sektor in etwa
wenn wir in Zukunft elektrifizieren in
Zukunft genau hinzu ich habe eine andere
Zahl für sie sagen sie sagen wir
brauchen 60% mehr Strom wir brauchen
übrigens auch durch Digitalisierung
deutlich mehr Strom die Prognosen hat ja
Robert habe gerade vorgestellt meine
Frage wenn wir den Autoverkehr
elektrifizieren wie viel Prozent mehr
Strom brauchen wir in Deutschland sie
müssen sich ja mit dem Thema ernsthaft
beschäftigt haben sonst kann man ja
nicht sagen
wenn wir 45 Minuten Verlängerung
Deutschland wenn wir komplette mit Strom
fahren in Deutschland wie viel Prozent
mehr Strom etwa ein Drittel mehr ich
habe eine andere Zahl für Sie okay
Herbert dies sagt den was aber dies der
Ex VW-Chef sagt mir was der die
Elektrifizierung vorangetrieben hat in
diesem Land wie weniger andere sein
Konzern scheint gerade zu korrigieren
aber ja nicht kennen dies sagt das
Ingenieur wir brauchen genau sechs
Prozent mehr Strom
definitiv falsch warum ist die Frage es
kann kein Zweifel daran geben weil die
Strommenge die wir bräuchten die
übrigens auch stetig produzieren
bräuchten deutlich höher ist ich keine
Zahlen von ein Drittel ich bin jetzt
Ökonom kein Ingenieur und natürlich ob
es der streitet aber natürlich streiten
gleichzeitig also er sagt das hat damit
das Bundeswirtschaftsministers
ehrlicherweise sie sagen wir brauchen 30
% mehr Strom 33 % in etwa 30 % wenn wir
alles elektrisch machen das werden wir
20 35 und nicht von Autos werden wir 20
Minuten LKWs kommen ja auch
möglicherweise dazu da redet die
Kommission ja auch gerade davon den
Verbrennungsmotor und die Geschichte mit
dem euel ja synthetische Kraftstoffe was
mich wirklich irritiert ist dass sie so
die Illusion erwecken da machen wir so
ein bisschen synthetische Kraftstoffe
und dann ist alles fein sie wissen doch
viel besser als ich dass wir
synthetische Kraftstoffe im Moment in so
homöopathischen Dosen ungefähr
herstellen
wir können die nicht in großen Mengen
herstellen also bei den synthetischen
ist doch so oder nicht heute heute
stellen wir sie insbesondere aus
Reststoffen her in ganz der Grund warum
die Branche ja genau das verlangt ganz
kleine genau das verlangt das sind
Dieselkraftstoffe dann alle Zukunft ja
Herrn zu müssen auch schon ein bisschen
an die Zukunft denken in Zukunft wäre
mein Ziel dass das was ein deutscher
Hersteller jetzt mit Chile macht
beispielsweise über Wind Energie mein
Ziel wie wäre es denn wenn wir ich
meinte Porsche an der Stelle wie wäre es
denn wenn wir beispielsweise mit Afrika
energiepartnerschaften machen dort
Solarkraftwerke aufbauen im großen Stil
und anstatt dass wir Kobalt für unsere
Batterien hier importieren also eher
Rohstoffe aus Afrika wegnehmen wie wäre
es denn wenn wir Afrika
industrialisierungsmöglichkeit geben
dass die uns dann synthetische
Kraftstoffe verkaufen wir müssen noch an
den Verkehr von morgen Decken zu hoffen
alles geht elektrisch diese Rechnung
geht aus meiner Sicht nicht ganz kurz
Peter sie haben kein Szenario und den
strombedarsteller synthetische
Kraftstoffe werden wie hergestellt
synkritische Kraftstoffe können aus
verschiedenen Technologien
ist insbesondere aus Sonne und Wind in
Sand und Sonnen- und windreichen
Regionen der Welt
aus Wasserstoff und CO2 ganz genau das
ist der zweite Prozess zunächst mal
brauchen wir Energie dann nimmt man Wind
und Sonne
aus Wasserstoff und CO2 exakt so wenn
das Grün sein soll auf der Luft aus der
Luft das heißt Sie müssen vorher mühsam
CO2 aus der Luft erst mal raus zusammen
ist keine neue Technologie
es ist eine Art Carmen capture müssen
sie rausholen so dann müssen sie
Wasserstoff haben das muss grüner
Wasserstoff sein das sollte das sollte
aus Wind und Sonne dann grün aber
energieintensiv
den herzustellen
damit haben sie kein Problem ja mit dem
Argument der Wirkungsgrad von e-fuels wo
ist der Wirkungsgrad von efeues der
reine Effizienz ist der liegt bei 15%,
15% darauf heben sie ab aber
mit dem gleichen Moment Prozent bitte
wirklich deswegen das meine ich
wirklich man kann auch nicht ernsthaft
für den Wahlkampf und weil man die FDP
retten will so eine Legende hochziehen
ist wirklich schön schön sie sie
konzentrieren sich gerade auf einen
Teilaspekt mit dem argumen Wissen mit
den Argument Wirkungsgrad eines
Verbrenner eines E-Motors wie hoch ja
was was nehmen wir denn dabei reden wir
auch von der Herstellung der
Wirkungsgrad eines Menschen genau
von der Herstellung der Batterie und das
was an Energie gebraucht wird und die
Batterie hat zu stellen mir tut
verstehen
bitte beantworten Sie doch bitte die
Frage wie hoch ist der Wirkungsgrad
jetzt gerade meinte ich ganz ehrlich
hoch welche Zahl meint sie ganz genau
Wirkungsgrad
relativ einfach das ist bei einem
E-Motor immer sehr hoch wie hoch immer
sehr hoch wie hoch mutmaßlich 80 90
Prozent ist über 90% über 90 Prozent das
heißt alles Energie nehmen aber warum
müssen sie da raten
wir reden hier über Energiewende wir
reden über die Frage wie wir Autos
betreiben und zu einer seriösen
Beschäftigung mit diesem Thema würde
doch gehören dass Sie wissen wie hoch
der Wirkungsgrad ist E-Motors ist oder
ich habe doch gerade gesagt
gut geraten das muss man doch wissen
wenn man sich mit diesem Thema
beschäftigt der das Problem ist sie
betrachten so viel der Realität gerade
was ist mit der Herstellung der Batterie
und jetzt reden weiter mit dem Argument
zu sagen es sei nicht ausreichend
effizient bestimmte Technologien müssten
wir heute die Herstellung von
Photovoltaik-Anlagen verbieten und die
den Einsatz von Foto bei talkanlagen in
Deutschland weil die können in Afrika
mehr als doppelt so effizient betrieben
werden der Ansatz mit Verlaub sagt auch
die Wissenschaft die sich mit dem Teil
beschäftigt ist ausdrücklich falsch das
Ziel ist doch nicht zu sagen wir schauen
uns einzelne Effizienz gerade an sondern
ob das System insgesamt funktioniert und
der gigantische Vorteil von
synthetischen Kraftstoffen im Vergleich
zu Strom ist dass sie speicherbar sind
dass sie transportierbar sind was ist
unser gigantisches Problem der
Energiewende in Deutschland speichern
haben Speicherung haben wir zu wenig wir
haben Transportprobleme an der Stelle
also das Problem was wir in der
Energiewende ohne Hilfe haben durch
Immobilität nur größer zu machen macht
nicht wahnsinnig viel Sinn aber jetzt
kommt
der letzte Satzzeichen ich bin auch sehr
viel Elektromobilität ich habe nichts
gegen Autos ich fahre selbst ein Hybrid
heran aber ich bin dagegen dass das was
die Politik die Klimapolitik der letzten
15 Jahren in Deutschland war aus allem
auszusteigen und sich das zu wundern
dass mein Klimaziele nicht erreicht
haben sich meine Politik ist lasst uns
möglichst viele Optionen nutzen warum
muss Politik schlauer sein als
Ingenieure und als das was in Zukunft
unter Umständen möglich ist die Profis
ranlassen ich bin sehr dafür dass wir
das ja jetzt kommt der Satz
den Markt überlassen ich habe davon auf
die 70er Jahre reagiert wenn damals
gesagt für Freiburg bin ADAC ich meinte
jetzt gar nicht in ADAC soll sondern ich
meinte insbesondere die Debatten die
damals geführt worden sind die mich ein
bisschen an heute erinnern ich habe
nämlich keine Lust auf Kultur Kampf ich
glaube da gibt es ein Kulturkampf ihr
den den kritisieren wir den Kulturkampf
nach dem Motto das Auto muss raus ich
liebe das hoffe das passiert in Hannover
am Ende nicht so ich wohne in der Nähe
von Bremen ich erlebe gerade wie die
Bremer Innenstadt gigantische Probleme
hat weil die dortige linke
Landesregierung versucht das Auto kaputt
zu machen und das finde ich schade und
ärgerlich ich möchte mehr Option haben
ich möchte dass Menschen in Zukunft die
Möglichkeit haben individuell mobil zu
sein
klimaneutral und dafür würde ich viele
Optionen machen und vor allem da darf
ich den letzten Satz anschließen und das
ist fast eine ja vielleicht eine
philosophische Frage auch von sozialer
Gerechtigkeit ich möchte nicht das
Autofahren individuelle Mobilität oder
wir haben vor ein paar Jahren über
Flugscheiben gesprochen ich möchte nicht
dass diese Dinge der Mobilität nur noch
verreiche sind ich möchte dass jeder die
Möglichkeit hat ein Sommerurlaub im
Süden zu verbringen das mit dem Flugzeug
hinzufliegen in Zukunft übrigens über
synthetische Kraftstoffe wenn Sie mit
den Airliner über Wasser möglicherweise
sagen ja die sagen aber vor allem wir
brauchen synthetische Kraftstoffe
bekommen
Menschen im ländlichen Raum die nicht so
viel Geld haben weiter mit dem Auto
unterwegs sein sollten das ist meine
Position